hey david could fighting vote by mail
in 2020 backfire horribly for
republicans i think it could i think it
could you know i went back and looked at
some of the history of this
in the late 80s started working
to expand the appeal of vote by mail
because republicans looked at the
demographics and they realized
we skew older and we may do
disproportionately better if we make it
easier to vote and voting by mail would
make it easier to vote particularly to
older folks who may
no longer be driving or may have limited
mobility
or for whatever other reason maybe would
be more likely to vote if it's easier
for them
and they started to work
on a plan to expand vote by mail
and to make sure that their electorate
knew that that was going on
those are the same i mean they're not
literally the same people but that's the
same republican party
that even in 2018 was still looking at
oh let's put a let's require a mail-in
a mail ballot dropbox at every early
voting site
in the state they were doing that in
2018. in comes donald trump
we have the pandemic and it really
starts to seem
that more vote by mail is going to be
bad for donald trump
so in 2020 the republican party doesn't
80 that a lot of people don't even know
is a 180 and starts opposing vote by
mail it'll lead to fraud
it'll lead to you know all these
different things that didn't happen
and it turned out that if it helped in
2020 it didn't help enough
in the sense that republicans still lost
the senate and republicans still lost
the white house but now there is concern
among some republicans including in
florida
that it's a runaway freight train that
can't be stopped the momentum of
stopping mail-in voting and indeed
dozens of the hundreds of bills that
we've seen put forward by republicans
since
the november election and since biden's
inauguration
would further limit early voting vote by
mail
etc strengthen voter id laws to make it
more difficult to vote all of that stuff
the washington post spoke to a florida
state republican party official who said
we are worried about this and so while
publicly
they feel the pressure to at least say
they're
in favor of all the stuff republicans
are doing florida republicans
know that uh particularly with
elderly and military voters which what
groups do they have left
even the military what both elderly and
military
went more for biden in 2020 than they
typically do for democrats but
these are two of the strongest
republican voting groups some
republicans in florida are
privately saying can we publicly push
this stuff
but then privately try to exempt older
people
and military to make it really easy for
them to keep voting by mail or voting
early or whatever the case may be so
the answer to the question could
opposing vote by mail
and early voting backfire on republicans
it absolutely could
what will they now do publicly to try to
figure out a way
to thread that needle i don't know and i
don't really care
if it does end up backfiring on them
it's it's they they have to uh what's
the you have to let you made the bed
now sleep in it or something like that
uh
eat the oats you sow i don't even know
i'm i'm looking for
proverbs and similes and analogies here
and failing
but this is a problem of their own
making and now they're going to have to
deal with it